today we've gone for two camera setup
because not only are we talking about
the Tesla Model y we're talking
specifically about all of the settings
inside of this main screen anybody
that's about to purchase the Tesla must
know all of these critical bits of
information because it is going to make
sure your car performs significantly
better and drives just the way you need
it to so let's dive into this screen and
talk about all of the Tesla settings you
need to know first of all to access your
actual settings you have to come down to
the bottom right hand corner and press
on the vehicle so for me personally what
I've done is set up the lights to Auto
but I have not turned the auto high
beams on the auto high beams will only
come on when you're driving on full
autopilot because these high beams
actually aren't that great in the city
and will blind some people so make sure
you have your auto high beams off during
everyday drive next on the list is the
auto wipers now I do believe the auto
wipers are pretty good from a day-to-day
basis so I do keep them on auto
personally the mirrors and recording
steering and everything here is where
you're going to have to set up your car
first from day dot and it will
automatically save it as you change the
settings in there if we come across to
our pedals and steering you're going to
see a couple more settings they're a bit
more complicated than most people would
think so you obviously have your chill
and your standard mode if you're ever
losing way too much battery and you're
thinking to yourself why am I losing way
too much change your acceleration over
to chill it will be significantly slower
it'll drive like a Grandma's car but it
will save a lot of battery so it is
something worth switching between if you
do need to actually preserve as much as
possible I find the steering mode set
into Comfort to be one of the easiest
and most practical it's not too soft
it's not too hard and you can get around
from day to day quite well I do
recommend having your stopping mode on
hold because if you are on a hill it
will hold your vehicle the whole time
whereas if you have it as a roll or
creep it'll kind of act more like a
regular car creep and roll could get you
into a bit of trouble because they could
roll away from the hill especially if
you are on a very steep incline so I
always recommend the hold feature coming
down to charging and as you can see my
vehicle is currently charging it's at 9
25 charge as we speak with about an hour
and a half left it is using the 15 amp
tail so it does charge a little bit
faster than the standard gpos however
here is where you can set your maximum
charging capacity my vehicle you see
there isn't a trip in a day setting it's
just 50 to 100 basically indicating that
you want to keep your battery over 50 at
all times for us it is recommended that
you keep your battery charged to 100 as
often as possible so if you need to
charge it simply come across slide this
little slider all the way to 100 and
you're good to go you can play and
adjust these scheduled settings for the
start time in your actual app as well so
our off-peak period here is 9am to 3 P.M
so we charge during 9am to 3 P.M most
times and we schedule that it part times
accordingly this means basically if we
plug it in at 8 30 8 45 it won't start
automatically charging until 9am which
makes sure we don't spend absurd amount
of power for no reason now once you get
into autopilot it gets a little bit more
complicated and it starts to change how
your car drives first of all auto steer
on beta is what you're going to want to
use to activate the basic autopilot
features the full self-driving
visualization preview doesn't give you
anything special it just changes what
you see on the screen here so when
you're driving you'll see little bins
and people and Road markings whereas if
you turn that off it'll be a very
simplistic kind of 3D generated
viewpoint on the right hand side when
you're on autopilot I like it having set
to speed limit rather than current speed
because that way you can avoid
significant fines in the city when you
go to fixed or percentage you can also
offset your variable speed so let's say
the speed limit is 100 kilometers an
hour and you've got it fixed you can
adjust that to one two three or even
four kilometers as you see fit and Leica
drive so for me I'm not too fast either
way I'm happy for it to be on zero and
as you see at the top whenever you
change something it automatically saves
scrolling a little bit further down we
have our automatic blind spot camera
which basically Once you turn on your
indicator it will turn the automatic
blind spot camera on the blind spot
Collision warning time again is just
another chime in the car it is helpful
so I do recommend keeping that on the
speed limit warning I personally hate it
I don't need to be reminded that it's
the speed limit every two seconds it's
the forward Collision warning set to
medium I think is appropriate because if
you go too late or too early it just
makes way too many noises hence why
we're going to get later on into Joe
mode because as you'll see Tesla's just
like to make lots of noise so forward
Collision warning set to medium is
perfect Lane departure warning as well
is great I don't like it on assist
because I don't like the car
automatically jerking back into the lane
especially when there's a lot of Lanes
on the actual Road it sometimes gets a
bit confusing for the vehicle and
sometimes pulls into the lane for no
particular reason now for the bottom I
don't like the traffic aware cruise
control chime and I don't like the green
Traffic Light chime just because there's
way too many sounds in this car moving
across the locks you're going to have
all your phones and all your keys set up
directly in here so when you get your
physical key you can automatically set
up your phone keys and then you can also
adjust all of your child locks your
safety locks how and what happens when
you walk away from the vehicle you can
exclude it from the home you can
automatically unlock in Park which is a
very good feature because otherwise you
have to come up to the top and tap this
little lock button which is a little bit
fiddly so as soon as you put it in park
the car automatically unlocks it's very
useful for helping people get in and out
of the car I do like to leave the car
left open notification on for both doors
and windows because there has been times
where we've left the phone in the car
somewhere in a bag somewhere in the back
or we've just walked away just not far
enough been sitting at lunch and it
hasn't locked so this is a great way to
make sure your car is either completely
locked or that everything is completely
closed because you don't actually have a
key or a start button or anything
getting in and out of the Tesla I do
like to keep the lock confirmation sound
on so when you're generally walking away
from the vehicle you're going to hear
that lock sound beep and you're going to
know in the back your head your car has
locked at the very bottom you can close
all of your wind Windows as you lock the
vehicle which is really good if you have
a winter environment it means your
vehicle will never get wet and you've
left the window open or the kids have
accidentally left a window open in the
back next we have our lights and we
touched on this a little bit so first of
all headlights definitely on auto dome
lights are your two lights up here in
the vehicle I don't actually like them
turning on when I get into the car
because this screen is so bright so
therefore I have them on off I do have
the ambient lights turned on and my auto
turn signals off now this is a recent
update to the Tesla where it
automatically turns the signals off and
on if you've left them on for a little
bit too long I just think the tech isn't
there yet couple more software updates
maybe I'll turn it back on but for now
it's just way too glitchy the last
couple of settings are obviously Auto
high beams like I said the auto high
beams just aren't there yet but
potentially with a few more software
updates they'll be good to go headlights
after exit are great because it means
you can walk away and still see where
you're going and the steering wheel
lights well there's not too much in
there so you can turn them offer on it
doesn't really matter next we have our
display and I like to keep mine on auto
because as the Sun's Up it stays nice
and bright when the Sun goes down it
converts to dark mode which isn't too
glaring in your face especially when all
of the lights in your vehicle at night
time are the screen it's a little bit of
a different experience driving at night
time so when it automatically turns to
dark mode is greatly appreciated if you
ever need to clean your screen this is
where you find it you just tap the clean
screen button it'll allow you to touch
and do whatever you want on screen
without affecting it and then you simply
press and hold for three seconds and it
will turn back to the full screen you
can also change some of your voice
recognition settings your time settings
your energy display for example
percentage or distance you can also just
simply tap that up the top there to
change it from percentage to kilometers
so that one doesn't have to go all the
way into your settings if we come across
through our trip we don't really use
this one too much anymore because now
with these new cards you can simply
swipe across
and it will tell you some great features
on the side so as we swipe across we
have all of our trip settings there
navigation is very simple Auto
navigation to home will work next
upcoming calendar event that one is
great it means you can simply just jump
in your car it'll automatically pull up
the next calendar event and Away you go
the trip planner is especially good as
well because once you're driving long
distances you want it to automatically
prepare the battery for supercharging so
keeping that one up and activated is a
great way to go safety features when we
go through this you always want to have
your Sentry mode on now Sentry mode does
use a little bit of battery so if you
want to conserve battery you can exclude
it from home work or your favorites and
you can change this from a camera based
to detection to only sensor based
detection now sensor based detection
obviously will only pick up the most
active and most close calls whereas
camera based will give you hundreds and
hundreds of activities throughout the
day so that one's a personal choice I
keep it on camera based just in case
when you first get into your Tesla
you're not going to have have the on
Honk dash cam activated which in an
emergency you're going to want to have
activated if anybody's about to get into
an accident and you slam on your brakes
hit your horn it's automatically going
to save that dash cam footage so it's
never Rewritten so that feature is
incredibly useful and I recommend
turning it on straight away you can turn
off the mobile access to your cameras
from inside so nobody can actually see
what's going on pin to drive is very
simple you put in a pin just in case
somebody's found your key and you want
to lock them out glove box pin again
safety feature I don't personally use it
because there's nothing in there but you
can activate it if you need if you want
to limit the speed of the vehicle for
example if you've got a student driver
or learner driver you can limit the
speed to 100ks an hour so they can't
actually go over it so it's quite a nice
little feature down the bottom in safety
as well you'll find cabin overheat
protection this one is really really
critical now obviously Tesla is a
predominantly glass roofs and glass
ceilings so you don't want them to crack
you don't want them to overheat and
you're happy to sacrifice a little bit
of battery for it I'm got the cabin
overheat protection on and there's more
in-depth settings into that in the app
so if you want to actually adjust the
temperature it kicks in on you can
change that in the app whereas here it
just makes sure the glass doesn't crack
on extremely hot days now like I
mentioned before Joe mode is incredibly
useful and Incredibly powerful because
the car makes so many noises so many
sounds so Joe mode basically just
doubles them down limits them and makes
sure you only hear the most important
ones okay we're getting through it now
we're almost at the very end service is
down the bottom and it tells you your
recommended PSI for your tires so for us
42 PSI all round 41 is okay I'm happy to
live with that one and I can inflate
them when I need to you can also have
all of your service manuals your tire
configurations and your deep deep dive
settings down the bottom in service
however most of this stuff you probably
won't touch ever in your life second
allowance is your software update and
this is also where you can change the
actual color of your Tesla if you wanted
to so for us I'm happy with the white
car because it is a white car but if you
get it wrapped painted or anything you
can come to software change the color of
the vehicle and move on down the bottom
we also have our software update
preferences and I like to have mine on
Advanced so I get the latest software
updates every single time last but not
least is our upgrades if we wanted to
update to premium connectivity we could
simply swipe across and update
automatically if you want to upgrade to
the full self-driving mode you can do
that in the app and not in the vehicle
because it takes a little bit more time
and obviously costs a lot more money so
they want to get that done properly
anyway that's all for me today guys
thank you so much for watching I hope
you enjoyed the video if you did make
sure you smash that like button down
below and also hit the Subscribe button
for more great Tesla content but like I
said that is all from me so I'll see you
next Monday